you are watching Congress check hello
and welcome to another ColdFusion video
to go go here
today's smartphone industry is starting
to solidify moving from the early
infancy stages to somewhat of a toddler
nowadays each manufacturer has to up its
own effort and continue to innovate just
to stay relevant samsung has unveiled
their new flagship phone for the Galaxy
S line in this video we'll take a quick
look at the s6 and its performance in
comparison to the competition and I'll
be voicing some of IANS throughout the
video generally speaking it will seem
that the theme behind the new Galaxy s6
and s6 edge is a mixture of redesign and
refinement
alright so let's get straight into it
and let's begin by looking at the specs
compared to the Galaxy s5 so the s6 is 7
grams lighter and 1.3 millimeters
slimmer than the s5 at just 6 point 8
millimeters the screen is 5.1 inches
diagonally with a pixel density of 577
pixels per inch this is compared to 432
pixels per inch on last year's model the
s6 has a whopping 3.6 million pixels
crammed in on that screen that's the
most of any device today there's also
now three gigs of RAM on board versus
two of last year's model all right so
let's peel a little bit deeper let's
look at the guts of this thing and see
how it compares to the other flagships
of mobile computing today under the hood
the s6 has a new processor the Exynos
7420 and many of you might be asking
where's the Snapdragon Varian well as it
turns out Samsung has actually divorced
from Qualcomm this time around as a
secondary supplier this new processor
actually breaks new ground as it's one
of the first 14 nanometer die process
chips to exist basically this means that
it's more efficient and uses less power
how much more efficient well compared to
last year's model which used a 20
nanometer die process it's 30 to 35
percent more energy efficient and in
addition to this it has 20% better
performance so while the new depressors
while some of you might know about
Moore's law it was a law proposed in
1970 by Gordon Moore and it states that
processor speeds or the overall
processing power of a
we'll double every two years and one of
the only ways to achieve this is by
cramming more transistors into a given
dye space so the smaller the dye process
the more transistors you can fit in
there so that's why this tiny 14
nanometer process is giving such great
advantages and these advantages have
translated into initial performance
tests the s6 and s6 edge have
exceptional multi-core number-crunching
performance crushing its main
competitors that being said the Tegra x1
wasn't included in these benchmark tests
this raw CPU power is good for tasks
such as web browsing extracting files
and loading long lists of items and
things along those lines the story is a
little different for single core
performance and it seems like the
iPhones just outperformed the s6 in this
case in terms of graphics for raw
performance without a screen
it's the HTC m9 first galaxy s6 second
and then the iPhone just trailing behind
when you start running tests and forced
the GPU to push 3.6 million pixels the
performance takes a hit and you can see
it here
the HTC m9 just screams ahead with
iPhone 6 not far behind and then the
iPhone 6 plus and then a considerable
distance behind is the galaxy s6 but
these results aren't actually as bad as
it sounds all current mobile games
should be able to run flawlessly but
just keep in mind in two years time this
may not be the case there's simply too
many pixels up there and before I
continue it might as well just be said
that benchmarks have to be taken with a
grain of salt but this just gives you
somewhat of an idea of general
performance okay so moving back onto the
specs unfortunately the battery of the
s6 is 250 million powers smaller than
the s5 and with all those extra pixels
to push some of you may be worried but
with processor efficiency up by 30% I'll
say it should all balance out in fact it
turns out that the s6 is battery
performance is just a hair under the
iPhone 6 plus except for music playback
all right let's move on to the camera
the camera is definitely a story of
refinement 16 megapixels on the rear 5
megapixels on the front both with an
f-stop of 1.9 which means more exposure
60% brighter on the front and 34%
brighter on the rear to be exact the
camera also loads up in the background
whenever the phone is awake so it
launches faster
there's also faster autofocus and
autofocus tracking optical image
stabilization makes return and
absolutely brilliant in the night for
said potential s6 buyers will be happy
about that one but unfortunately when it
comes to the UI it seems that Samsung
has shamelessly stolen some ideas from
HTC okay let's move on to the design as
they say beauty is in the eye of the
beholder and many be holders out there
find this phone beautiful but I'm not
actually whole heartedly one of them
unfortunately for me at the front and
the sides of the device look great
although the top and bottom bezels could
be a bit smaller for a more attractive
proportion and I think the design
language in regards of the trims of the
phones does seem to have a slightly
bulbous nature and when you flip the
phone around at the unsymmetrical
fingerprint scanner in combination with
that camera mount design just doesn't
sit right with me but that's just my
opinion though Gorilla Glass 4 back
panels refreshing but may be of some
concern to those who aren't a fan of
phone cases because you know we've all
seen the smash backs of the Nexus floor
or iPhone 5 and 5s --is ok so there's
been a fair few changes to the design
that this has come at a cost there are
two main trade-offs to this new design
and it may annoy some people out there
number one waterproofing and water
resistance has now gone from the phone
and number two there's no removable
battery or SD card storage anymore for
some smartphone enthusiasts these issues
could make or break your purchase but
for the general public mainly they is
coming from an iPhone or phones with
shielding batteries will probably not
mine too much one other gripe that I
have with the design of the device is
the bottom although it looks good I'm
somewhat disappointed by Samsung's lack
of creativity here because really
there's a y plethora of design
combinations that you could use for the
bottom of any phone but this clearly is
borrowing from the iPhone 6s design
language some people out there may not
care but I'm just not too keen on it
I think Samsung should be more like HTC
in this regard finding their own unique
design groove making it so good that
other people want to copy from you and
not the other way around
but to Samsung's credit the s6 edge is
pretty unique I'm glad that fixed on the
design issues with the edge edition
namely that the edge runs along both
sides of the device and I could just
imagine how natural will feel to swipe
in from the side of an app whose UI
demands that kind of motion the facedown
notifications are pretty cool as well so
you get a subtle indication of when
someone is trying to contact you
Samsung is also built certain software
around this like tickers alarm clocks
and something called people edge where
you can pull up your favorite
color-coded contacts with a swipe from
the edge of the screen and I might also
add that the price point this time is
correct having this the same price of
the regular s6 actually makes sense this
time now this means that it's a
variation of the s6 and not somewhat of
a different premium range the price
point was an issue that had me rather
reserved about the note for edge so in
conclusion
despite some design quirks my initial
thoughts and the s6 and s6 edge are
mostly positive and if you're out there
and you don't mind giving up a bit of
graphics performance for a very high
screen resolution and are a fan of the
design I definitely think the s6 and s6
edge would be worth a look it's probably
a worthy upgrade for someone who has an
s4 but for s5 owners or Note 4 owners I
think these guys will still get a lot of
extra mileage out of their phones as for
me I am personally happy with my note 4
and don't really see a reason to change
to an s6 but who knows when the phone
comes to stores in Australia I go in
have a quick play and see what I think
about it anyway thanks for watching
hopefully this video has been quite
informational for you and you've found
some extra things that were useful to
you and if you have don't forget to
share it along to someone who'll be
interested give it a thumbs up write a
comment and subscribe thanks for
watching guys I'll see you again soon
for the next video
Cheers